hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mesenchymal stromal
or stem cell msc workflow for efficient
clinical translation
from automated gnp compliant cell
manufacturing
to standardize phenotyping i'm michelle
ashton of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by miltoni biotech
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.miltonebiotech.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
catherine gothard the project manager of
research and development at miltoni
biotech
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen catherine you may now
begin your presentation
okay thank you very much for the
introduction
i'm happy to present you today this
webinar
room and i would like to talk about the
methane chymous roman
cells workflow for efficient clinical
translation
so this is first our disclaimer and i
continue now with some interesting facts
regarding miltoni biotech
so the company was founded in 1989
and up to now we have around about 3
000 employees worldwide from
about 15 different nations so it's quite
an
international company i'm part of the r
d department as
these are about 23
of all the employees so we have
developed during all the years up to 70
000 different products and different
um research region and also into in the
clinical field
so that up to now around about
65 000 cell therapy
procedures have been taken
place using multibiotic products
so about 2 500
patients were treated per year with
their products using our technology
so that shows you all that our passion
is
to have a nice product portfolio from
benchtop to bedside so all the products
we have
support researchers all over the world
in the
research field but also in
their way to go into the clinic later on
come now to the part of the msc
workflow we would like to talk about
today
so the improved film and xeno-free
cultivation
solution i would like to focus on now
so first to come to the msc workflow
which
is yeah worked on at many different labs
all over the world
so starting with the sample the primary
tissue
so bone marrow adipose tissue umbilical
cord all these
tissues are quite um
bearing some amazing chymostromal stem
cells
these cells are separated
for example by different markers or by
plastic appearance
further the these cells are circulation
expanded in large scale or small scale
some quality control is done
those different functions are analyzed
and later on the final cell product is
maybe prior
preserved or directly used
for the different applications
so what milton is doing is that
we are providing um a lot of different
products
to support this msc workflow and even
here
it's quite important for us to have this
seamless translation from basic reach
research to clinical research
and to show you in more in more details
how this look like i would like to focus
on the msc isolation and expansion
so always questions come up so what is
needed to overcome
challenges when working in msc
field and the main
problems here are the improvement of
cell culture products to have better
methods for expansion of mscs
and to get some help
in complying with the relevant gmp
guidelines or regulations
so we are focusing here to support all
these needs
and therefore we have developed
different cell culture medias
for msc isolation and expansion for
example
we have these fcs containing media and
also
xeno-free media so xeno and theorem free
media and i would like to
point out that we have one medium
in a gmp grade
to support also all the higher regulated
needs
and to to show here
one very important feature
so if the customer or
if researchers start in the research
field they can use the xeno-free stem
max msc expansion media xf
which is yeah xenon theorem free no
additives are
necessary here for adhesion of mscs to
the plastic so no coating of surfaces
and we have the same formulation
or also available as a gmp version of
this media
so even this media is also sino and
serum and also phenol red free
it's supporting an efficient expansion
of human embassies from different tissue
sources
also from the primary tissue
no substrate pre-coating of the culture
results
is required
and as you can see here we are flexible
a back size is available so this is the
two liter bag which you can see on the
picture with the corresponding
supplements
and also a 500 milliliter bag is
provided
this medium was developed in compliance
with
relevant gmp guidelines designed
following the recommendations
of usp 1043 on ancillary materials
and it's manufactured and tested under
an e013485
compliant quality management system
so i'd like to show now some more
details about
our quality analysis of this media so we
have done a lot of
experiments here to show that mscs are
working quite nice after expansion
so first here we wanted to show how the
clonogenic potential looks like
of our standmarks mscxf medium as well
as the
gmp version of this medium the msc brew
gmp medium
in comparison to the homebrew
alpha mem and dmem media
as well as the comparison to two
commercially available cell culture
media
so as you can see here
mainly commercially available media
needs some input of
a b theorem to support
the adherence of mscs coming from
primary tissue
this is not the case for our stomachs
xf and the msa brew medium so we have
better msc adhesion
results in a higher number of cf
colonies using the stamax medium and the
msc brew
and furthermore there is better msc
proliferation
resulting in larger colonies so the
beside the number of colonies we have
analyzed here
the number of mses within
one dish this is depicted
within the dots in this graphic and
yeah as you can see here the multani
media
are supporting the proliferation even at
the beginning of the culture
quite nice
also if if you are interested in a
clinical scale expansion of
msc so so to say
about generating 200
000 200 million mscs
it's possible to do this quite fast so
just within 15 days
starting with 10 milliliters of human
bone marrow
using the stamax medium and the msc brew
you will reach these high number of
cells
compared to the home brew dmem and alpha
man media which
takes a lot more so more than
three weeks roundabout to get this high
number of cells
so the positive effect here that we
achieve a clinical scale msc number
with less media consumption so
we are just using 50 to 70 percent
of the media which is normally used for
homebrew media
and the reason for that is because we
are
saving about um yeah
14 days 15 days after reaching this high
number
of mscs with the msc brew gmp media
but not only this
low passaging cultivation
process is optimal we also looked for
large-scale expansion so also for higher
passages so msd blue gmp medium allows
for stable expansion of mses
here we have looked for this
for up to six passages and yeah
the proliferation range is quite
nice quite comparable with all both ml
multi-media and it's
improved compared to the homebrew alpha
mammond
dmem media but what's going on with the
cells then
after expansion so of course this is a
question
how functional are the cells so
therefore
we have done some functional essays
one of course a very important topic
is the expression of msc specific
surface markers
for this purpose we have used the msc
phenotyping kit
a flow cocktail
including different markers to stain
cell surface
and antigens analyzed then by flow
cytometry and we can show here that the
relevant
mfc markers are expressed by the cells
even yeah also the
differentiation media were used for
differentiation capability so for adipo
site differentiation osteoblast
differentiation and chandra side
differentiation
what is also quite interesting for many
researchers is the immune modulatory
potential of mses
after difference after expansion
so here we use the msc suppression
inspector to look for the t
cell suppressive potential of mscs
and as you can see here the potential is
quite preserved and
quite high compared to the homebrew
media
shown here in this graphic
what is new here is we have updated the
msc phenotyping kit
and here now i would like to show you in
more detail
how standardized and reliable this
phenotyping cocktail is
so the design of the msc phenotyping kit
is as follows so you can do around about
50 tests with one
kit the kit is consisting of an msc
phenotyping cocktail
and an isotype cocktail as well as fixed
individual antibodies for compensation
control
so this is quite important to get a
reliable result at the end
the phenotyping cocktail contains
all the relevant mfc markers cd73
cd90 cd105 as well as the non-msc
markers
and the hladr as recommended by the ict
consortium
so it facilitates standardized and
reliable phenotyping of cultured human
mses from different tissue sources
this is just one example showing human
mses
cultured in stem max msc xf medium and
analyzed by the msc phenotyping kit
showing a high expression of cd 73
90 and 105 the non-msc markers are
negative
and which is also a nice feature that
the hladr antibody which is
in most cases also a negative negatively
expressed on the cells can be analyzed
with a separate color here and this is
quite important because sometimes mses
are stimulated
like you can see here so the stimulation
can be done
by antiphon gamma or tnf alpha
to have a look of the
msc function in more detail but
sometimes it's also
the case when for example in fcs
containing media
a high amount of interference gamma is
present
then sometimes the hladr signal is quite
high
so therefore it's really nice to have
this marker
with a separate color here in this kit
to analyze it separately from the other
non-msc markers
because as you see here before
stimulation it's negative and after
stimulation with interferon gamma and
tnf alpha the signal is
quite high
the hybridoma antibodies
are quite an old technology
they were used in the old antibody kits
so this technology is from 1970
antibodies are produced as a hybridoma
in mouth and then later on in the
hybridoma cell culture
so the new way to produce
antibodies in a recombinant way
using here our affinity antibodies
is based on a system of a mammalian cell
production system
producing recombinant antibodies
antibodies
consisting partly of a human
and a mouse part
and there you have some benefits of
these rare affinity antibodies for
standard analysis
so first they are recommend generated
and they have one universal igg-1
isotype that improves of course
the reproducibility of
the essays in the lab later on
furthermore there is a mutation
a mutated fc region and this
improves or reduces the background
signal
so summing up these the kit is quite
easy to use
the five chiral antibody cocktail
includes three positive and five
negative antibodies for msc phenotyping
in addition an isotype control cocktail
and six individual antibodies for
compensation control
are also included
the assay is very standardized because
antibodies are included
that are defined by the isct consortium
for msc characterization by flow
cytometry
there is a really high lot to lot
consistency and repeat rebut
reproducibility because all the used
antibodies are reaffinity recombinant
antibodies
the kit is very reliable
because we use different flowchromes
for the hladr antibody to distinguish
between activated and non-activated mscs
i would like to come up now to the next
topic so which is sorting
mscs via the max quantity
so sorting cells bear
several problems so for example when you
sort cells with a cell sorter there's
high pressure and
shear stress affecting the viability and
function of cells
decontamination cleaning of fluidics
required after each run
there is a high chance of carry over
between different runs
and even when you are when we are
talking here about these
rare cells carry over is quite an
important topic
adjustment of drop delay and laser
alignment is needed
so the decompression of cells affect
viability and the functionality
application of charge affects viability
and function and might of
and might alter gene expression
safety concerns due to aerosol forming
or alternatively working under huge
biosafety cabinets
contamination of the sample affects
downstream processing so all these
these points are quite problematic and
therefore we have now the max quantity
it's with its unique features so it's
really gentle
to the cells because it has very low
pressure
no decompression enables resorting of
functional cells
and we have no cellulose in tubing sets
because the whole procedure takes place
in the cartridge and the
all cells are remaining in this
cartridge
the max quantity is fully sterile so
cartridge provides a closed system
so the cartridge system also
[Music]
gives some opportunity not to have any
carry over from
experiment to experiments because you
need
and use a separate cartridge for each
experiment
and do we do not have any contamination
of fluidics
so it's fully safe system the absence of
aerosol and droplets
and no biosafety cabinet is needed
the device is really easy to use so it's
a benchtop device no adjustment
of drop delay or laser alignment needed
and no cleaning required
so this cell sorting process here at the
title is
shown in more detail in this picture so
you really have
yeah no pressure no charge
less aerosol or no aerosol
development so at the end cells are
quite feeling well are very viable and
not activated in any
kind of process within here
so for the mscs we have done several
experiments
to use this device the max quantitative
for sorting using cd 271 and anti-msci1
as
specific markers expressed
on mscs coming from bone marrow
so we used bone marrow mononuclear cell
fraction
labeled with cd 271 pe
and anti-msca1 apc
[Music]
and you can see here before separation
there's
this is a really really low um
frequent cell population with only 0.04
percent
and after separation um there's a really
really high enrichment of cells
of more than ninety percent
also the viability is quite nice and if
you then
put these cells after sorting and also
compared to the situation before sorting
in culture you can
see that there's a high increase in
clonogenic potential
in these sorted cell population
here we analyzed the ability of cells
to expand and proliferate after the
sorting
process we have
passaged the cells several times and we
can
show here that the sorted cells grow in
a
comparable manner but like the plastic
appearance cells
also the marker expression is as it is
as it should be for mscs and also here
we looked for the t cell suppression
suppression potential so it's quite
preserved and comparable
before and after sorting
but besides sorting of course the
cultivation process is still important
and
many people would like to do here a
closed procedure an
automated procedure so therefore we are
providing the new clinimax prodigy
adherent cell culture system
so gmp compliant cell manufacturing is
really complex workflow
including a lot of many different
processes so
cell preparation surface coating
cell cultivation media change harvesting
and for all these processes many
different devices
are are needed and as well
you all every everything has to done in
clean rooms
so we will like combine all these steps
within one machine within the clinimax
prodigy
to have the integration of these various
cell processing steps
so the hardware here some description on
that
the clinimax prodigy platform is an
integrated and closed
system for automated set processing from
starting material to final cell
product what we can do is sample
preparation for example the density
gradient centrifugation
to isolate mscs from bone marrow from
bone marrow for example
cell washing is possible media change
magnetic fat separation
cell stimulation genetic modification
and final product formulation
so the closed system from sample to
product that is what we want so
therefore we have
the single use disposable tubing set
sterile filters at input ports
there is possibility of sterile welding
for example using the tirumo device
integrated qc sample pouches
are integrated within the tubing set to
make it easier
for qc sampling
and doing essays in between taking in
process
controls during the expansion process
so for cultivation we have several
options
first the centric cult unit you can see
it here on the
right side the surface area is around
100
square centimeter for adherent and
non-adherent cell cultivation
automated feeding and harvesting
processes are possible here
so we have a temperature control because
the centricult unit
is placed within the device and is part
of the whole tubing set
and the device is also supporting these
centric cult unit with a defined
atmosphere so co2
for example five percent co2 10 co2
whatever the cultivation
requires there's visual cell examination
possible by an integrated microscope the
microscope is also part of the clinimax
prodigy and we have multiple input ports
for different
media or cytokines of course these 100
square centimeters might not to be
sufficient for different for all the
different applications
especially for the msc workflow um
it is not sufficient so therefore here
customers have the possibility to
connect an external culture weather to
the tubing set
and then it's possible to have a
scalable fan manufacturing process
now coming to the tubing set it's gmp
compliant
and it's possible to do sterile welding
during the process
it has integrated several bags and
sample pouches
for passaging and qc
it's easy to connect an external
cultivation weather as
it is shown here via the dead end tube
and you cannot only connect one
for example cell stack to these dead end
you can
also connect up to three cell stacks
the five layer cell stacks for example
the whole tubing set is compatible with
the upcoming clinimax electroporator
for gene manipulation
so showing now here in more detail the
gmp compliant msc expansion workflow
using the clinimax prodigy adherent cell
culture
system so everything starts again also
here with the bone marrow
and the whole process then is automated
within the machine
so having the density gradient
centrifugation
seeding of cells
media change harvesting
and seeding again in different cell
culture
external cell culture vessels up to
the last harvest of the target cells
so the process is quite um handy
and quite optimized
to reduce the manual hands-on time
so here within this process we have
reduced the hands-on
time to about 70 percent
the process is not only available
for bone marrow to isolate ms from bone
marrow but also
you can do this with enzymatic digested
umbilical cord or enzymatic digested
adipose tissue and also
here you of course find the same reduced
hands-on time because of all the
automation of the different steps
so we prepared again here some
data on using this prodigy process for
manufacturing of
mses in large scale from bone marrow
umbilical cord and adipose tissue
and in all cases you can see quite quite
nice
that with a low amount of
primary starting material after
not more than two or three passages
we end up in a
quite high amount of of mscs
up to 700 million mscs were prepared
here
but of course this number can extend it
of course on the one hand by starting
with a higher amount of
starting volume or extending the
cultivation
period so here in these experiments we
cultivated the cells for yeah up to
14 or 15 16 days
so summing up now i am
we have a complete workflow for
efficient clinical translation
the workflow is sterile and gentle
for example for cell sorting of mscs
using the
maxquan title
we have an efficient msc expansion with
serum free and xeno3
msc brew gmp medium
and we have talked about the gmp
compliant msc expansion using the
clinimax protegeiter and cell culture
system
using the msc phenotyping kit it's
possible to do it standardized and
reliable
phenotyping and analysis
of mscs after cultivation
so you see here now again the msc
workflow
and all the different solutions
we have talked about during this webin
webinar to support the msc workflow for
example
for preparation of the primary tissue
using the gentlemax for example for
umbilical cord dissociation
for doing the cell preparation using the
clinimax
prodigy or the max quantitative
cell expansion using the gmp compliant
cell culture media or different
cytokines
doing the quality control using the msc
phenotyping kit
based on the flow analysis doing some
cryopreservation of cells
afterwards and then having the final
product
available
so i would like to thank you now for
attending this
um this workshop thank you very much
thank you catherine for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first
question is compared to other
commercially available kits
what are the advantages of your msc
phenotyping kit
okay so our msc phenotyping kit
includes three positive markers and a
set of negative markers
including cd14 cd20 cd34 and cd45
the cocktail does not does contain pe
fits apc
and it also includes
a separate negative marker hladr
which is visible
with another color beside the other
negative marker and this makes it
possible
to analyze cells which are
stimulated or not stimulated via the
hladr expression of cells
furthermore we have included here
quite high standardized
recombinant reaffinity antibodies which
improve the reliability
and the specificity of this antibody
cocktail
great thank you okay next question says
do you have other kits or antibodies to
test the function
of cultured mses
so yes we have so beside the
phenotyping or the marker expression
a lot of people in the field are
interested
in analyzing the immune modulatory
potential
of mscs and here we are providing the
msc
suppression inspector this
is a kit to look for the
potential of mscs to suppress t cell
proliferation and this is quite a very
important function of mscs
and necessary for a lot of different
clinical applications
where mscs are currently investigated in
furthermore beside the suppression
inspector we are providing
differentiation media for adipocyte
differentiation osteoblast
differentiation and
chondrocyte differentiation
great thank you now in your opinion for
which application
sorting approach is helpful and can you
give us some examples
okay yeah i think so the sorting of mses
is very important in all cases where you
would like
to analyze the primary mscs
in more detail so the primary mses which
are
in the primary tissue in the bone marrow
in the adipose tissue
or in the umbilical cord for example
because here and this
tissue with the msc number is really
really really low
so as we have seen in the presentation
before the now the frequency is round
about 0.01
to zero point zero five percent
roundabout
and um to analyze these cells um
in more detail a sorting approach is
quite helpful
for example if you would like to do gene
area analysis
or something comparable with these
primary
mscs so only with this sorting
sorting approach you get a high
purity of these uncultivated
untouched cells
and there are different markers which
can be used for this approach
for example city 271 and the msca one
of course another
another reason why people would like to
sort mscs
is of course if they have defined
a specific antibody for a subpopulation
of
mscs primary mses or cultured mscs
this could be another interesting
example for a sorting approach
thank you okay it looks like we have
time for one more question
and we will finish with this question
can you talk a little bit more
about cell yields using your platform to
culture mscs
and to what extent can you upscale the
system
okay sorry can we repeat this question
i i came yeah
please repeat this question
sure can you talk a bit more
about cell yield using your platform to
culture
mscs and the second part of the question
says
to what extent can you upscale the
system
okay yeah that's also a good question so
in our experiments we have cultured the
mscs
from the different tissues to up to
700 million cells and for this approach
we have used
six uh two or three five layer stacks
depending
on the starting material
but of course it could be upscaled even
more
so if you would like to start with a
higher amount of cells
at the beginning or to continue the
cultivation period
even then you can extend
the whole system by using
six five layer stacks and these would
then
result in a surface area of about
20 000 square centimeters
but i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and further questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitting during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank
catherine for her time today
and her important research we would also
like to thank
labruz and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labrads will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye